we are told select the two fractions
that are greater than one
so pause this video and see if you can
figure out which two of these fractions
are greater than one
all right now let's work on this
together and so the main realization
here the main thing to pay attention to
is how the numerator relates to the
denominator
when we are at one they're equal to each
other for example one is equal to one
whole i guess you could write it that
way one once you could also write it as
two halves is also equal to three thirds
is also equal to four fourths we could
go on and on if we wanted in terms of
six 1 would be equal to 6 6.
and so if whatever we have up here is
larger than the denominator so if we
have 7 6
or if we were to have
maybe five fourths notice the numerator
is larger than the denominator these are
all situations when we are greater than
one and all the situations where the
numerator is less than the denominator
so example one-half or
nine elevenths
or
ten
elevenths
these are all situations where we are
less than one oh this is less than one
so let's look over here
four
is less than 6. 4 6 is less than 6 6.
remember 1 is the same thing as 6 6. so
this is not greater than 1 so i would
not select that
9 4 well that's definitely larger than
four-fourths that is greater than one
and once again our numerator is larger
than our denominator so we know that we
are greater than one so i will select
that one
and then we see again five halves
two-halves is equal to one so
five-halves is definitely greater than
one so i like that one as well and
notice five is greater than two
and then we already know we picked our
two choices but we can look at the other
ones seven is less than eight so seven
eighths is less than 8 8. so this is
less than 1 and 3 3 we've already talked
about it that's equal to 1. so i like
those two choices
let's do another example that that
tackles it a little bit of a different
way it says what which fraction could
represent point a on the number line and
point a is here they don't tell us a lot
about point a but all they do tell us by
looking at the number line is that point
a is less than one
so which of these another way to think
about it is less than 1.
all right in order for it to be less
than 1 the numerator has to be less than
the denominator here our numerator is
greater than the denominator 7 4 is
definitely larger than four-fourths
remember four-fourths is equal to one
this right over here i could rewrite as
four-fourths and so seven-fourths is
going to be some place seven-fourths is
going to be some place over there so
this is definitely not our choice
two halves well once again that's the
same thing as one that's right over
there so that's not our choice what
about 5 8
well 5 8 the numerator is less than the
denominator 8 8 is equal to 1 so that's
that point again so 5 8 would be to the
left of that so that could be point a so
i like that choice